la première chose à établir c'est
pourquoi faire de la luge de vitesse
limite mais vite comment c'est ce cas là
bas on évite les arbres la vitesse est
belle ça me fait rigoler juste prendre
un peu de muscle et faire des jobs
d'ailleurs si on n'est pas refroidi par
ce qui est arrivé à son ami je crois que
c'est un genre sont en dessous discret
au fil à sa faim mouvement pile à la
jambe a claqué des traumatismes parfois
lourd les hôpitaux pour enfants on voit
beaucoup trop ces temps-ci autant en
trois semaines quand un hiver complet
principalement des blessures à la tête
donc des commotions cérébrales des
saignements même au cerveau des
blessures au niveau du visage dédain
c'est ce genre de configuration qui
inquiète les équipes en traumatologie
une pente assez prononcé une section
d'arbres non protégés et puis en bas de
la piste un peu de foin autour de cet
arbre quelques mètres et la rue juste
après je parte
j'ai vu deux ans même cette protection
de foin n'en est pas vraiment une
dieu à la température ça ça gèle et puis
ça devient quasiment comme un bloc
dessus
et les adeptes de la luge glisse bien
souvent la tête la première
95 % 2 n'ont pas de casque de protection
donc une suggestion c'est de mettre la
case de hockey le casque de ski parce
que les conséquences d'un simple choc
peuvent se ressentir longtemps après
l'impact
son papa fab et des mathématiques de
base 2 x 2 yaris luc à montréal il y a
une trentaine de buts dédiée à la glisse
dans les parcs avec des corridors bien
délimiter ce qu'on en sait on ne les
espaces aménagés
on a du personnel un gratuit 100 pour
réglementer tout ça dans les grands
parcs notamment donc vraiment il faut
utiliser les espaces qui sont aménagés
et sécurisés
si mature au scra du canada merial